die ich heute erlebt habe und man merkt
ja dass man emotional sich nur engagiert
wenn man sich ärgert oder mit ärgert ich
habe mich mit hans ulrich jörges mit
geärgert und wir alle gesagt das kann
doch wohl nicht wahr sein aber das ist
ja deutsche wirklichkeit die geschichte
hat er nicht erfunden sondern erlebt und
ich habe mir heute wegen meines immer
schlechter werdenden regens eine massage
geleistet eine freundliche vietnamese
namens lama hat sich geärgert und ich
habe angefangen mich mit ihr mit zu
ärgern die sagt ich bin seit zwölf
jahren in diesem land sprach perfekt
deutsch habe nie einen euro aus
irgendwelchen sozialsystemen bekommen
und meine ganze familie wir sind fünf
leute hier das eine ist ein ehepaar ihr
bruder und seine frau leben in bayreuth
so weit ich das richtig verstanden habe
und sie wollen ihre 70 jährigen eltern
nach wohl selbstverständlich um sie
quasi aufzufangen und sie hier durch
zufüttern also es geht nicht darum dass
die eltern irgendwelche sozial ansprüche
stellen es geht nicht sie sagt sie
dürfen es nicht aber ihr rumänischer
nachbar hat zehn verwandte nachgeholt
ohne probleme von denen keiner auch nur
einen job hat von denen keiner arbeitet
und die alle in irgendeiner form schon
mit der absicht gekommen sind es sich
hier gut gehen zu lassen so hat sie mir
das geschildert ich habe keinen anlass
daran zu zweifeln weil sie das mit einer
inbrunst und einer auch verzweiflung mir
erzählt hat ich verstehe es nicht da
gibt es offensichtlich regularien und
das ist das problem was wir in dieser
runde öfter schon gehabt haben es gibt
staatliche gebote und verbote die
anderen menschen das leben zur hölle
machen die wir nicht nachvollziehen
können wenn wir nicht uns entweder einen
pass abholen oder den rücken massieren
lassen ja das ist so
romanes eu da geht das ja vietnam nicht
obwohl jeder weiß dass die vietnamesen
enorm fleißige leute sind die würden nie
aber im amt klingeln sie haben die zeit
gar nichts da stundenlang anzustehen die
arbeiten und arbeiten und die die kommen
mit dem ergebnis ihrer arbeit aus
während also ich sags liebe dich ich
sag's aber jetzt die bettelbanden die
bei mir vom supermarkt sitzen und sich
ständig ablösen und nur betteln und ich
kenne die gesichter alle die kommen aus
rumänien
das ist ein perfektes beispiel dafür ist
ich würde mich längeren umtreibt es gibt
wahrscheinlich gar keine
ausländerfeindlichkeit nein sondern es
gibt eine faulen und abzocker feindlich
gehabt genau das das was du damals haben
sie das gefühlt und das finde ich wie
die war also fleißig richtig genauso wie
jene bei denen jeder würde doch bei dem
beispiel sagen der vietnamesen muss man
quasi mit offenen armen begegnen dir
nicht helfen die familie nachdruck soll
das ist da ist auch das war
familiennachzug drin wir machen es aber
so jemanden schwer der bereits
weitgehend integriert ist und auch die
eltern waren es in dem fall integrieren
würde dafür empfangen wir nach meinem
eindruck mit viel zu offenen armen
leuten über gar nicht kennen die sich
noch nicht bewährt haben ja schon
bewusst dass derjenige oder diejenige
die hier schon ist den die schon nur von
der sozialhilfe lebt
dann wissen wir ja was nachkommen wie
hat denn ihr kriegt man auch gegen inne
hat und ich glaube halt uli dass diese
diese abgrenzung wie du richtig erweise
vorgenommen was das ist ja der
politische kontext sozusagen eu und
nicht eu dass man das menschen ähnliche
mittel krieg dem land sondern man kriegt
nur ist gut strengt sich an hat unsere
hilfe verdient oder ist faul zockt ab
und wollen wir hier nicht haben ganz
ruhig und dass das ist völlig egal ob
aus welchem land da jemand kommt und
wegen beruf ausübt und ob der mann oder
frau groß oder klein deutsch sprechend
oder nicht deutsch sprechend ist wobei
da würde ich noch sagen so ein bisschen
mühe kann man sich schon geben wenn man
in einem land ist aber das spielt
eigentlich keine rolle sondern es geht
darum wie sich jemand verhält und nicht
wo er herkommt oder was er ist sondern
wie er sich verhält und dafür ist das
denn eigentlich
bedenkliches beispiel ein schönes auf
der einen seite aber auch in
abschreckendes auf daran ja es hat mich
bewege tools gibt jetzt eine diskussion
darüber über die aufnahme der restlichen
länder vom balkan in die eu da muss man
auch genauer hingucken serbien hat ein
riesen wirtschaftswachstum der das geht
richtig voran würde der eu tun davon bin
ich fest überzeugt die alten serbischen
sünden aus dem krieg sind ziemlich
abgearbeitet und vergessen und mit
bewältigen haben sie noch lange zu tun
glaube ich während der andere die
kleineren staaten auf dem balkan wege
nicht sicher was da passiert also was
passiert wenn familien mitglied der eu
ist ja aber angela merkel war jetzt dort
und sagt alle sollen mitglied werden das
läuft natürlich gegen größere schaffen
große vorbehalte olivas der wirt goldene
zeiten für die albanische mafia ja weil
dann sozusagen die
aufenthaltsgenehmigung in deutschland
praktisch vom staat mitgeliefert wird
also ich glaube da es muss eine
möglichkeit geben das in gewisser weise
nicht von einer staatsangehörigkeit
abhängig zu machen sondern von dem
willen hier mitzumachen wir müssen uns
auch umgekehrt mal vorstellen wenn
deutsche bürger und bürgerinnen ins
ausland gehen würden wie viel hilfe
würden die den bekommen die müssen sich
anstrengen die müssen nach paar tagen
danke sagen können und bitte und wo geht
es um jahr und wie gehen das ist auch
eine mentalitätsfrage mir war das ja
auch so wenn ich in amerika unterwegs
war und mehr sagt einer du darfst am
strand nur flaschen in einer tüte
rumtragen sage ich das ist völlig
unsinnig aber und wenn man mir seine
zweijährigen kinder dürfen nicht ohne
windeln unterwegs seien sonst kriegst du
ein ticket sage ich man kann einen
zweijährigen und gewinn dass diese
diskussion kommt erst gar nicht gesagt
dann ziehen wir in gottes namen ihm die
windel an und dann stecke ich dann ist
das nicht wie sie reagieren das
einsortieren haben und wird mal ein
polizist grad zu sagen das ist noch die
autobahn und da muss ich sagen hat er
recht gehabt weil ich gefahren bin als
wäre ich zwischen nürnberg und münchen
aber das interessante ist ein
interessantes beispiel weil
umsatzrückgang jedenfalls der
mehrheitsgesellschaft wäre wir müssen
jetzt akzeptieren dass der mann seine
flasche nicht in die tüte steckt und
dass der seine kinder ohne windeln denn
wir können daher als gastgeberland in
you know how das ist ein kulturelles
thema und ich
frage
das ist wohl wahr aber ich finde dieses
von lucia das ist sozusagen etwas was
man ja auch als jemand der ein neues
land kommt nun steht erst vorher wir
wollen ein solches land gehen und würden
dann dem monstrum eines waren ja in
dieser deutschen wenig sagen
widerstandsrat erzogen aber ich ziehe
keine schuluniform nie im leben sich
diese nach vier wochen hat er hat er die
socken darf ich dazu aber gar nicht
anziehen ja um gottes willen dann müssen
wir in dem buch nach gucken welche
socken
alle natürlich bei unserer tochter die
war ja ein jahr in los angeles auf der
internationalen schule war riesen
geschreiben mit dieser uniform dann
wurde der rock heimlich noch 2 cm ab
genäht dass er die speziellen maße nicht
einhielt als sie zurück also sie weinte
am ersten tag der du wolltest sagen als
sie zurückkamen oder länger gemacht
sagte sie ach du schande jetzt geht das
morgens wieder los welchen brand hat die
an welche gene das war da war es da ging
es nur darum nicht was er anhat sondern
wie sozial er sich verhält dass das
finde ich spitze ja damit keine sozialen
unterschiede gibt den man sehen kann das
machen macht wirklich einen sinn das
heißt also du hast du warst auf einem
guten wege mit seiner moderation ich
glaube auch es gibt keine
ausländerfeindlichkeit bei uns es gibt
ein unverständnis für gewisse gruppen
die sich entweder nicht integrieren
wollen oder nicht integrieren können
oder in irgendeiner form
da darf da wächst bei uns ein unmut der
vielleicht nicht menschlich und nicht
nicht zeichen eines großen geistes ist
aber der nachvollziehbaren und den haben
aus meiner sicht viele menschen nicht
nur gegenüber menschen die aus anderen
her eins ist natürlich die haben es auch
gegen die eigenen menschen und sagen der
oder die will ja gar nicht arbeiten
selbstverständlich müssen wir mit lights
gelder zahlen für menschen die behindert
sind die eingeschränkt sind zu alt sind
aber egal auf der welt du musst dich
anstrengen muss da ein lebensunterhalt
verdienen uns nicht absolut wie ich das
ja auch die normale menschliche reaktion
jeder menschen mit anderen menschen
kontakt haben sie denn was schaffen er
will was sehen eher mildes zustande
bringen so und wer das nicht will der
also irgendwie verloren verlegen und
zwar überall ja und wollten das ist
glaube ich dass das das ist eigentlich
die geisteshaltung die die sich
eigentlich verbreiten müsste
[Musik]